whenever you see something about Canada
mentioned in the US show there's bound
to be a Canadian involved with it who's
making some sort of Canadian joke and
there are quite a few Canadian jokes
which are instantly understandable to
Canadians and sometimes baffling to
other people running a turnip for prime
minister would probably can be
considered unbecoming levity in many
countries they would never do it
whereas Canadians have a reprehensible
habit of making fun of just about
everything
that it's always cold let me see what
else might they have you tell me you
tell me they'll tell you a Canadian joke
see if you get it so it's not my joke
it's a joke by somebody called Nancy
white who said what does a Canadian girl
say when you asked her ask her if she'd
like some sex she says only if you're
having some yourself so one of the
Canadian jokes is that Canadians have
this ultra politeness which is not
always true